il aurait sans doute préféré attendre un
ciel plus clément pour commencer les
vendanges mais frédéric guéguen a pas
une minute à perdre son raisin commence
à pourrir c'est du botrytis un
champignon botrytis cinerea donc on voit
ce mycélium qui se développe sur le
raisin et après ça contamine les autres
gras a qui sont tout autour et au final
la grappe se dessèche et après y'a plus
rien du tout et ce n'est pas le seul
problème qui le rencontre avec sa
récolte cette année il estime ses pertes
à plus de 70% en grande partie à cause
d'un gel record au printemps dernier
n'est pas une surprise mais ça fait mal
la conséquence c'est qu'il ya certains à
pied où aucune baguette n'est reparti ou
parfois ce sont des bourgeons de
deuxième génération avec des raisins
plus petit et parfois pas de raison
l'équipe du vigneron bruno verrait lui
prête main forte ils ne font pas de
crémant cette année faute d'assez de
raisin alors ils ont encore un peu de
temps avant d'annoncer leurs vendanges
qui seront tout aussi calamiteuse ça
s'annonce entre triste et désastreux
quoi on sait pas trop
on imagine faire avoir quoi faire 20%
d'une récolte normale donc à savoir pas
grand chose avec des grosses disparités
d'une parcelle à l'autre mais voilà ça
va être très très compliqué
très compliqué ça l'est de plus en plus
dit celui qui est aussi président du
syndicat des bourgognes les aléas de la
viticulture sont devenus en quelque
sorte les premières loges des
changements climatiques mes parents
n'avaient jamais commencé les la récolte
au mois d'août et moi sur bientôt 30 ans
où je suis multiculture j'aurais fait
j'aurais commencé dix fois les
dix fois la récolte au mois d'août et on
remarque aussi que tous les éléments qui
nous touchent en plus en plus violents
on a eu des orages de grêle comme jamais
on n'a vu on a eu des épisodes de
canicule comme jamais on n'a eu hélas on
a des épisodes de gel d'une rare
violence à des périodes où normalement
on a plus de gueule quoi comme la vaste
majorité de leurs confrères les deux
vignerons n'ont aucune assurance pour
compenser les pertes qu'ils subissent au
gré des événements climatiques il n'y a
pas de compensation possible
ce sont des choses qui sont assurables
bien entendu mais c'est souvent des
assurances qui sont chères compliqué à
mettre en place donc beaucoup de
viticulteurs ne sont ne sont pas assurés
ça pourrait changer dès 2023 le gel du
printemps a ramené sur la table un
projet de fonds d'indemnisation pour
compenser les pertes agricoles à la
suite des calamités climatiques
ce régime universel d'indemnisation sera
doté de 600 millions d'euros soit deux
fois plus que les sommes actuellement
prévus
le ministre de l'agriculture a confié la
mission de réviser le fonds de gestion
des risques actuels ou député frédéric
descrozaille s'il ya urgence de revoir
les compensations pour que tous les
secteurs agricoles soient mieux protégés
il faut aussi voir cette mesure comme un
pont vers une transformation majeure des
cultures pour s'adapter aux inévitables
conséquences des changements climatiques
il est certain que dans les années qui
viennent certains risques assumés par
les assureurs vont progressivement cessé
de tenir assure apci l'occurrence
devient répétées et certaines par
définition assureurs couvrent des aléas
pas des certitudes il s'agit de se les
poser collectivement puisque c'est
compliqué de délocaliser des productions
mais c'est bien ce dont on parle et de
se donner les moyens pour que ces
décisions soient accompagnées d'une d'un
transfert de risques par les assureurs
on hésite entre tous entre est-ce qu'il
faut se diversifier
est-ce qu'il faut encourager nos enfants
à reprendre parce que
une année comme cette année on sait
qu'il va fort se réinventer au niveau de
la culture parce qu'il va falloir qu'on
fasse pas un con qu'on puisse faire face
aux temps au gel de printemps qu'aux
gros orage de grêle qui a tout ce qui
peut venir de perturber tout ce qu'on
connaît pas encore donc tout ça il faut
qu'on apprenne à faire face mais voilà
on est on est des terriens avant tout
c'est à dire qu'on a les pieds dans la
terre ça doit surtout aujourd'hui les
pieds dans la terre et le choeur
enraciné dans le terroir synonyme en
france de tradition et d'identité et
c'est bien cette essence même du
territoire qui est menacé et qu'il faut
maintenant penser réinventer ici marie
ève bédard radio-canada saint bris le
vineux